Transcriber: Marina Naguib
المدقّق: Yahya Mansour
تأثرت للغاية بثلاثة قصص في حياتي وجعلوني
أتصرف بطريقةٍ مختلفة عن باقي الناس،
القصة الأولى حدثت عندما كنت
طالبًا بالجامعة،
كان معي زملاء أجانب بالجامعة وأردت
أن أخرج معهم،
وذهبت معهم إلى مكانهم المعتاد الخروج
إليه، وهذا المكان يسمح بدخول الأجانب فقط.
فعندما رأي الرجل على بوابة المكان الهوية
الخاص بي سألني هل أنت مصري؟ آسف لا يسمح لك
تأثرت بالموضوع للغاية، كيف أنني بمصر ولا
أستطيع الاستمتاع بالأشياء الموجودة ببلدي!
وشعرت أنني لست ببلدي وينبغي عليّ أن أسافر،
لن أعيش في هذه البلد مجددًا،
وبعد أول إجازة لي قررت أن أسافر إلى لبنان،
بينما كنت بشوارعها رأيت صفًا من السيارات
تسير بشكلٍ جميلٍ
ودخلوا إلى مكانٍ
يُعقد فيه مناسبة، فدخلت بعدهم،
فأوقفني الرجل على البوابة وقال لي
ممنوع الدخول،
فسألته إذا يوجد تذاكر وسأدفع لأني أريد
الدخول للمشاهدة ما يحدث،
فقال لي أنت لست لبنانيًا فرددت قائلًا نعم
أنا مصريٌ فسمح لي بالدخول، ولم أفكر فالأمر
لأنني كنت أريد مشاهدة السيارات فقط، وعندما
ذهبت للداخل وجدت شخصًا أو 2 بجانب كل عربة
فأخذت الإذن من شخصٍ واقفًا بجانب عربةٍ
أحبها للغاية،
أخبرته أنني اريد مشاهدة العربة من الداخل،
فسألني أأنت لبنانيٌ؟ فأخبرته أنني مصريٌ،
فسمح لي بالدخول قائلًا أنني لو كنت
لبنانيًا فلم أكن لأدخل،
لا أعرف ما سبب ذلك
ولكنني أريد رؤية السيارة
بعدها رأيت السيارة وبعدها ذهبت للفندق،
وكان لدي سؤالًا مهمًا ألا وهو لما هناك
أشياءً بمصر ممنوع منها المصريون؟
ولما هناك بلبنان
أشياءً ممنوع منها اللبنانيون؟
هذا هو الوطن العربي، لا يعطي أبناءه أي شيء
فكل الأشياء للأجانب والذين يعيشون بالخارج،
فقررت أنني سأسافر لبلادٍ غير عربية،
سأسافر لبلادٍ كأوروبا وأمريكا،
بلدًا بها ديموقراطية والكل سواسية.
وقد حدث، فالإجازة التالية كنت بأمريكا، و
هذه صورتي بجانب البيت الأبيض،
وقد تعرفت على رجلٍ أمريكي يدعى آرثر
وكان يتنزه أيضًا بواشنطن،
فقررنا التنزه معًا، فإلتقطنا بعض الصور
أمام البيت الأبيض وبعدها ذهبنا للكونجرس
وإلتقطنا بعض الصور داخله وبعدها سألت آرثر
لما لم نلتقط صورًا لنا
بداخل البيت الأبيض؟ فأجابني قائلًا غالبًا
لا ينفع التصوير بداخله فقلت له أن نسأل،
فذهبنا إلى مكتب الإستعلامات وبالطبع آرثر
هو الذي تحدث
لأنه أمريكيٌ، فسأل السيدة الواقفة إذا كان
مسموحًا بالدخول للبيت الأبيض
فسألته من أي ولايةً أمريكيةً أنت يا آرثر؟
فأجابها من أنه من ولاية (..) فقالت له ماذا
عن صديقك، من أي ولاية؟ أجابها بأنني من مصر
فقالت له يجب على صديقك أن يذهب الآن
وفي خلال نصف ساعةٍ
إلى السفارة التابع لها ويحضر تصريحًا
بالدخول للبيت الأبيض وسيدخله اليوم،
أما عنك فستذهب لحجز ميعادًا مع السيناتور
المسئول عن ولايتك،
وقد يأخذ من إسبوعًا إلى ثلاثة أسابيع، ومن
بعدها ستعرف موعدك وتذهب هناك
ليتحدث معك ويعرف ماهية توجهاتك السياسية و
سيحكي لك عما يفعلونه لأمريكا،
من ثم تطلب منه تصريح الدخول ومن الممكن
أعطاؤك التصريح ومن الممكن لا،
وعلى الأرجح سيعطيك التصريح.
فتضايق آرثر معللًا
بأنه يومًا واحدًا الذي يمكننا
التنزه فيه ولايوجد وقت لكل هذا،
فكيف أنني أمريكيٌ ولا يمكنني الدخول؟
أنا كنت مذهولًا
وتأكدت أن هناك شيئًا  لا أفهمه،
فالأمر أكبر من مصر وأمريكا ولبنان،
هناك شيئًا آخر.
وفي نفس اليوم، أدركت أن الإنسان المختلف
دائمًا ما يُعامل بطريقة حسنة، ولكن ما
الإختلاف؟ لا يمكنني أن أحدد ذلك
فإذا مشى رجلٌ عاريٌ في الشارع، هذا
يُسمى اختلافًا
ولكن الناس سيرموه بالطوب.
فهناك نوعًا من أنواع الاختلاف
إذا كان لديك هذا الاختلاف -الذي لا أستطيع
تحديده- فالتعامل معك سيكون جيدًا.
ولكنني تأثرت بذلك.
وبعد ذلك، سافرت إلى روسيا،
ورأيت شيئًا ما أبهرني للغاية
رأيت شبابًا في الثمانية عشر وهم متزوجون،
أنا أعرف أن بمصر يوجد ذلك أيضًا
ولكنهم غير ملتحقون بالجامعة
ويتركونها ليبحثوا عن أي وظيفة كي يجنوا
المال منها ويعيشون،
أما في روسيا فكان مختلفًا عن ذلك، فكانوا
يدرسون بالجامعة وفي كلية علوم الكمبيوتر،
تزوجوا ولكنهم لم ينجبوا لأن كلاهما يدرس
بجامعةٍ واحدةٍ.
وحياتهم جميلة فأنهم يذهبون للجامعة معًا،
ويعملون معًا، ويتنزهون معًا.
ولكن الشيء العجيب بالأمر أنهم تزوجوا
وعاشوا معًا بمالهم الخاص
مما يعني أنه عمل وهو صغيرٌ
بوظيفةٍ تجعله مؤهلًا للزواج،
وهذا عادةً لا يحدث في مصر، فأنا تزوجت وأنا
30 عامًا ولم أرَ ذلك في حياتي من قبل
فكيف لشخصٍ أقل من العشرين عامًا وله مرتبًا
يجعله قادرًا على الزواج؟!
لا أقصد الزواج تحديدًا
بل أنه يفعل ما يشاء فهذا أبهرني للغاية.
والقصة الثالثة التي تأثرت بها هي قصتي
الشخصية والتي كانت عن تعليمي،
وأنا في الثانوية، كنت لا أدري ماذا
أريد أن أفعل،
وكنت أتمنى أن أفعل شيئًا جديدًا وممتعًا
أريد فعل شيئًا للناس في كان أنحاء العالم،
ولكن ما هي؟ لا أدري.
فقررت أنني سألتحق بإدارة الأعمال،
لما هذا التخصص نحديدًا؟ لأنني أردت أن أكون
متفوقًا في الأعمال، ما هي الأعمال؟ لا أدري
ولكن عندما أحدد ما الذي أريد فعله،
سأديرها بشكلٍ جيدٍ.
فدرست إدارة الأعمال لأربع سنواتٍ،
وفي عامي الأخير وكنت قد شارفت على التخرج،
بدأ جميع أساتذتي التحدث عن شخصيةٍ
عظيمة قد ظهرت في الآونة الأخيرة أعني منذ
20 عامًا،
وذلك الرجل كان “بيل جيتس” وكان الناس
يشيدون به كثيرًا،
وبأنه من أفضل رجال الأعمال
فأعتقدت أنه أنهي رسالة الماجيستير
والدكتواه بما أنه رجل أعمال معروفًا،
فسألت عنه وعن تعليمه،
فعرفت أنه لم يدرس هذا المجال، بل أنه درس
البرمجة
ماذا؟ أفضل شخصٍ بإدارة الأعمال لم يدرسها؟!
فماذا أفعل بالجامعة؟
فشعرت بأن حياتي تدمرت،
فأنا أدرس بالجامعة لأربع سنوات لأعرف أن
أفضل رجل أعمال لم يدرسها في الأساس!
ففي عامي الأخير،
بدأت بدراسة علوم الكمبيوتر،
ورأى معظم الناس أنني أضيّع حياتي وخصوصًا
أنني على مشارف التخرج،
ولكنني لم أحب هذا المجال،
وكنت أريد أن ابدأ في شيءٍ أحبه، فبدأت
في علوم الكمبيوتر
وبدأت أن اسأل على بيل جيتس وماذا يفعل،
فأتضح أنه من انشأ نظام “الأوبريتنج”، هذا
جميل
سأصنع واحدًا مثله فهو ليس أفضل مني!
فأشتريت كتب هذا النظام وكل متعلقاته،
وسأتعلم هذا الأشياء وسأفعلها. فقضيت 4
سنوات بهذا الكلية،
وفي السنة الرابعة أنشئت سيستم
“الأوبريتنج” الخاص بي ولكنه لا يعمل،
ويظر شاشة سوداء بها اسمي فقط،
فلا يوجد أي أزرار أو أي شيء آخر بهذا
النظام، ولكن أحسست أنني فعلت شيئًا،
فعلت شيئًا،
وأن في المستقبل القريب سيستخدم جميع الناس
النظام الخاص بي،
ولن يستخدموا نظام بيل جيتس مجددًا،
فبقيت أحلم كلما نمت
بأن بيل جيتس يبكي في التليفزيون قائلًا
ان شركته أنهارت
وأن الناس يستخدمون أشياء هذا الرجل وأنه
سعيدًا للغاية بذلك.
وفي اليوم التالي، فتحت الكمبيوتر الخاص بي
وفجأة الشاشة فرقعت،
لا أعرف ما الخطأ الذي وقعت به، فالجهاز كان
طبيعيًا ليلة أمس،
فأخذت الجهاز للصيانة وكان ذلك قبل العيد
ب 10 أيام،
فكلما ذهبت لأحدٍ يخبرنني أن
آتي له بعد العيد،
لم يعرفونني وأنا الذي كنت سأشتهر بعد يومين
وسيضعون صورتي على الجنيه المصري
فإستأذنته أن يصلحه لكنه رفض، وطوال هذه
ال 10 أيام كانت أزمةً لي لأنني سأضيعهم،
ولكنني لم أهتم وقلت لنفسي أنني سأستغلهم
في الذهاب إلى أساتذتي بالجامعة وأن اسألهم
عن الأشياء التي لم أفعلها،
وأريد أن ألفت انتباهك إلى أن النظام الخاص
بي لا يوجد به أي شيء
فإذا وضعت الذاكرة الفلاشية أو هارد ديسك
لن يقرأهم وسيفتح شاشةً سوداء،
وإذا كتبت أي شيء لن يحدث شيء، فمازال
أمامي الكثير لفعله
فذهب لأساتذتي لأسمع آرائهم
لأرى إذ كان بوسعي تطبيق كلامهم، فوجدت
أستاذًا ممتازًا وأجرى رسالتي الماجيستير
والدكتوراه في نظام “الروبوتنج”،
فكنت سأستفيد منه كثيرًا؛ لذا ذهبت إليه
وشرح لي كل ما يتعلق عن هذا النظام،
وكنت سعيدًا للغاية، ثم سألته إذا يوجد
المزيد؛ لأن هناك بعض المعلومات الناقصة،
فأخبرني أنه لا يوجد أي معلومات أخرى
بالإمتحان، فأعتقد أنني اسأله بهدف النجاح،
ولكنني أريد انشاء نظامًا خاصًا بي، فأخبرته
عن فكرتي فأجابني بأن كل الذي ندرسه
هي أشياء نظرية لا يمكن أن يطبق فالواقع،
صدمت وأخبرته أنني أدرس بالكلية لمدة 4
سنوات ويتضح بأنه لا يمت للواقع بصله!
وهذه بالنسبة لي كانت أزمةً وتأثرت بها
للغاية، فكنت أفكر كثيرًا
عما يحدث بنا، ولما دائمًا الناس تحب التقلي
د على الرغم أن المختلف يعامل باختلاف؟
ولماذا يقولون للطلاب أن يركزون بدراستهم؟
وأن هذا هو عملهم!
فهناك بعض الموظفين قد تزوجوا ويعملون وبنفس
الوقت يدرسون
ولماذا يزعمون أن الكلية هي أهم شيء بالرغم
من أنها أشياءًا نظرية؟
فتأثرت بشدة ومن بعدا كنت أفكر لما لم أفعل
أي شيء في هذا الموضوع؟
فقد أضعت حياتي لأنني أكشفت ذلك في
الثلاثينات من عمري!
فحتى إذا وجدت حلًا سيكون متأخرًا ولن أستفي
د منه بشيء ولكنني حزينًا طالما لم أجده.
ففكرت فكيفية إصلاح حياتي ولما قد لا
أستطيع فعل ذلك.
فقررت أن أرى الخيارات المفتوحة أمامي،
فوجدت خيارين وهما:
شركة برمجة وموقع لتعليم البرمجة،
وموقع تعليم البرمجة مخصص فقط لطلبة الكليات
فعندما كنت غاضبًا من الكلية أنشأته
لتعليم طلبة الكلية ما الذي نحتاجه في العمل
وليست الأشياء النظرية كما يحدث في الكلية.
لكنه لن يفيد الأصغر سنًا الذين يريدون
مزاولة المهنة،
فأول شيء فعلته كان إلغاء هذه المناهج
واعداد مناهج أخرى جديدة بطريقةٍ سهلة
حتى يفهمها جميع الناس.
أما الشيء الثاني وهو كيف للصغار أن يعملوا؟
الكبار يمكنهم بسهولة فعل ذلك،
ففكرت بشركة البرمجة الخاصة بي، فكل مهندس
يعمل بالشركة يمكنه أن يحضر شخصًا
من الذين أنهوا التدريبات المتاحة على
الموقع، للتدريب بالشركة.
هذه جنة، لديها 13 عام وقد أنهت كل
التدريبات الموجودة بالموقع
والآن تدرب بقسم تحليل البيانات. وأريدكم أن
تعرفوا ماهية التدريب في شركتنا،
نحضر طالبًا للتدريب ومعه مهندسٍ، وعندما
نجد عملًا،
نأخذ منه نسختين، نسخة للمهندس والأخرى
للطالب،
فيقوم المهندس بإنهائه وتسليمه للعميل، أما
الطالب فيقوم بإنهائه وتسليمه لي لتصحيحه،
متى ينجح الطالب بالتدريب؟ عندما يتبع
خطوات المهندس ويفعل مثله
وعندها سأكون متأكدًا تمامًا أن هذا الطفل
الصغير قادرًا على الإنتاج كما المتخرجين،
فمستواهم تمامًا مثل مستوى طلبة الهندسة.
وهذه الفتاة ذات ال 13 عامًا وكانت تتدرب
لمدة سنة وخمسة أشهر،
وفي الشهر الماضي، أنهت كل التدريبات وكانت
تمشي على نفس خطى المهندسون،
فهي في قسم تحليل البيانات وهي 13 عامًا فقط
وتعمل كالمهندسين،
فماذا إذا أصبحت 20 عامًا أو إذا
إلتحقت بكلية الهندسة؟
أما هذه الفتاة فهي تدعى روان، ولديها 14
عامًا وتتدرب منذ أكثر من عامٍ
فهي تتدرب من فترة طويلة، وقد أنهت
التدريبات وقررت أن تبقى بالشركة،
فأخبرناها أنها قد أنهت تدريباتها بالفعل
ولكنها رفضت وفضّلت البقاء
وهي الآن تعمل معنا وعملها أكثر من رائع
لدرجة أنني أعطيها مرتبًا،
فلا يجوز أن يقوم أحدًا بهذا المجهود
بلا مرتب. والآن هي تعمل و
تتلقى راتبًا وهي 14 عامًا فقط.
فماذا سيكون مرتبها عندما تصبح 16 عامًا؟
أما تلك الفتاة فهي جودي، ولديها 14 عامًا
أيضًا، وقد أنهت تدريبها،
ونريدها معنا بالشركة لأنها متفوقة، كما أن
لديها حلمًا بأن تُنشئ مشروعًا ضخمًا،
ولا يوجد لدى شركتنا أي مانع ولكنها الآن
بالصف الثالث الإعدادي،
يجب عليها المذاكرة فلا يوجد لديها وقتًا.
هذه مايا، ولديها 14 عامًا، وقد فعلت
شيئًا غريبًا،
كان هناك طلبة من كلية الهندسة بالأسكندرية
معها في التدريب،
فبعضٍ من هؤلاء الطلبة لم يكملوا التدريب،
وكانت هي الوحيدة التي أنهته،
فمستواها أفضل من مستوى
ناس بالهندسة، فماذا سيحدث عندما تدخل
الهندسة؟
أما عن هذا فهو زياد وهو عبقريٌ
فكان يتعلم البرمجة وهو 10 سنواتٍ فقط ولكن
قبل أن ينضم إلينا، وانضم إلينا
منذ أكثر من عامٍ،
وكلما أعطيناه مهمة، يقوم بها بشكلٍ أفضل
من المهندسين بنفسهم،
لأنه درس أشياءً اخري نحن لم ندرسها بالكلية
كبرمجة الألعاب،
فعملنا بالشركة ليس له علاقة ببرمجة الألعاب
،وكان يدرس أشياءً أخرى لا نستخدمها
فدائمًا ما كان لديه أفكارًا أفضل، وفي يومٍ
ما جاء إلى قائلًا أن لديه فكرة لمشروعٍ
أيمكننا تنفيذه؟ وبعدها شرح لي هذه الفكرة،
فأجبته قائلًا أنها رائعة ويمكننا تنفيذها
فقلت إن شاء الله كعادة المصريين فيمكن
تنفيذها العام القادم أوشيئًا من هذا القبيل
وبعد 5 أيام وجدت زياد قادمًا وأنهى المشروع
أجبته قائلًا ممتاز لم أتوقع ذلك ولكنه قال
لي أننا بحاجة لمصممٍ ومصورٍ وأشياء أخرى،
فأجبته قائلًا الذي تحتاجه أفعله يا زياد
أنتهى المشروع وكان زياد المسئول عنه وتحت
يده يعمل المصورون وناس أخرى،
وكل ذلك والمشروع مكتمل ونجني منه مالًا،
وكل ذلك بفضل طفلٍ ذو ال15 عامًا يعمل
كمدير للمشروع ويعمل لديه بعض الناس،
وسأعينه رسميًا في الشركة بعد أتمامه لل16.
وأريدكم أن تتخيلوا ما الذي سيحدث عندما
يذهبون للجامعة ويتخرجون.
وهذا أحمد ومن بعده عبدلله،
كلاهما لديه 17 عامًا وكلاهما يعملان
بالشركة،
في تدريباتهما كانا متفوقان ولم يسبق لأي
مصري أن يفعل هذه الأشياء،
فلم يسبق لهما أن تأخرا على التدريب ولم
يغلقا هاتفيهما أبدًا وقت العمل،
والتي نادرًا ما نجدها بمصر، فأنهيا
تدريبيهما وعملا بالشركة بسرعة
وأنا متشوقٌ لأعرف ما الذي سيفعلونه
عند ال18 عامًا
فعندها مرتباتهما ستزيد وسيكونا قادرين على
فتح بيوتًا،
ويصرفا على نفسيهمها، هل سيتزوجان أم
سيسافران؟
بالنسبة لي، فأريدهما أن يتزوجان لأنني أريد
رؤية الأشياء في مصر كما رأيتهم بالخارج،
أنا قد أنهيت كلامي الآن، وأعرف أن معظم
الحاضرين أقل من ال20 عامًا،
وجميعهم قادرين على العمل، ولكنني أعرف
الظروف التي تمرون بها وتجعلكم تشعرون
أنكم لستم كفايةً وأن أمامكم الكثير من
الوقت لتعملون، فقد مررت بذلك،
أنا هنا لكي أخبركم أنكم كفاية ويمكنكم أن
تعملون
وأن الأطفال إذا وجدوا الفرصة للعمل،
يتصرفون أفضل كثيرًا من الكبار،
ويحققون أشياءُ، أنا لم أحققها إلا بعد
سنواتٍ
فمثلًا زياد أصبح مدير للمشروعات وهو 15
عامًا فقط، أما أنا فأصبحت كذلك في ال30،
فنحن لم نعرف كيف نفعل ذلك لأن لم يكن هناك
أي داعم للموضوعِ،
فأنتم اليوم لا تحتاجون لأي داعمٍ، فأنتم
موهوبون،
ويمكنكم تحقيق العديد من الأشياء، أبحثوا عن
وظيفة من الآن واعملوا،
وإذا لم تقبلك شركةٍ ما ف اتركها وابحث عن
غيرها، لا تنتظروا
فأنتم من تصنعون النجاح وليس الآخرين،
فأنتم الذين تبحثون وتعملون وتصنعون، وزياد
لم يصل لهذا المكانة بسبب ترقيتي له،
ولكن لأنه جاء لي وتحدث معي عما يريده،
فنجح بعدما حقق ما يريده، لهذا عندما طلب
شخصًا آخرًا وافقت،
كلما نجحتم كلما أعطاكم الناس فرصًا أكثر،
ولكنهم لن يعطوكم ذلك إلا بعد نجاحكم،
أما عن أول نجاح فلا أحد يعطيه لكم، أنتم من
تصنعوه وأنتم من تتعبون لتصلون له.
أنتهيت، شكرًا.
(تصفيق)